WHICH IS "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
LEAVE A COMMENT IF YOU ARE
THERE.
IT WILL GO UP ALSO ON
FOXNEWS.COM.
FOR REACTION TO WHAT YOU
JUST SAW COLUMNIST MARK
STEYN JOINS US.
THAT CONVERSATION GOT ME
THINKING ABOUT SHE ASKED I
THOUGHT A GOOD QUESTION WHY
DO PEOPLE DISLIKE HILLARY
CLINTON SO MUCH?
AND I ACTUALLY THOUGHT ABOUT
IT BECAUSE HILLARY IS NOT
THE MOST OFFENSIVE ON POLICY
AMONG ALL DEMOCRATS BUT SHE
GRATES.
WHY IS THAT?
I THINK IT'S BECAUSE THIS
WEIRD THING THAT SHE DOES
WHERE SHE SELLS HERSELF AS A
VERY STRONG FIGURE AND I
THINK SHE IS TOUGH,
ACTUALLY.
ONE THING I LIKE ABOUT HER.
AND WHEN ATTACKED
IMMEDIATELY RETREATS INTO
THE VICTIM POSE.
YOU CAN'T SAY I'M A WOMAN
YOU ARE SEXIST.
THAT'S UNFAIR.
THAT'S NOT GOOD
SPORTSMANSHIP.
PICK ONE.
ARE YOU FEROCIOUS AND TOUGH
OR WEAK?
>> THAT'S A PROBLEM.
BUT THAT DUALITY AS IT WERE
DERIVES FROM HER ROLE.
SHE IS NOT ONLY SOMEONE WHO
IS A POLITICIAN IN HER OWN
RIGHT, BUT SHE WAS ALSO, FOR
MANY YEARS, AND THIS IS HOW
SHE CAME TO NATIONAL
PROMINENCE, THE SPOUSE OF A
PROMINENT POLITICIAN.
I THINK THAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE.
I WAS STRUCK BY THE SUBTITLE
OF JENNIFER PALMIERI'S BOOK
AN OPEN LETTER TO THE WOMEN
WHO WILL RUN THE WORLD.
WELL, ACTUALLY, OUTSIDE THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY AND OUTSIDE
AMERICA WOMEN DO RUN A LOT
OF THE WORLD.
I DON'T HAPPEN TO AGREE WITH
THEM.
ANGELA MERKEL HAS
SINGLE-HANDEDLY WRECKED
EUROPE BY LETTING IN
MILLIONS OF FIRESTONE
BOLOGNA REFUGEES.
WOBBLY ON BREXIT.
WHAT THEY'RE NOT IS THE WIFE
OF THE PREVIOUS GUY WHICH
DOESN'T PASS THE SMELL TEST.
AND YOU CAN'T SHATTER THE